hallo herzlich willkommen in meine
torten meldet heute herr mache ich
pancakes und zeige euch wie ich sie eben
hersteller
es gibt jetzt rezepte wie man die
herstellen kann mir persönlich ist ganz
wichtig dass sie lustig sind und fluffig
weil hier auch ziemlich dick sind und
eben dann nicht so schlimm marken liegen
sondern so eine richtig schöne leichte
masse sind und ich werde dieses rezept
jetzt für drei personen machen das ist
ein ganz einfaches rezept also pro
person rechne ich ein ei und eben dann
die anderen zutaten mit dazu meine
pancakes sind etwas weniger süß wenn sie
gerne etwas süßer markt kam er zu mir
dazu geben wie gesagt ist dieses rezept
jetzt für drei personen
falls ihr sucht oder unter rechnen
möchtet könnt ihr das natürlich auch
gerne machen das ist dann auch ganz
einfach und jetzt zeige ich euch einfach
mal schnell die zutaten und zeigt an wie
es weitergeht
für drei portionen braucht ihr drei eier
drei esslöffel zucker 150 gramm mehl
drei teelöffel backpulver und eine prise
salz und ich habe jetzt mal probiert
einen teelöffel backpulver durch einen
teelöffel natron zu ersetzen
und dann braucht ihr 300 milliliter oder
300 gramm milchprodukte
ich nehme jetzt hier 200 gramm joghurt
mit etwas mascarpone vermischt und 100
km 1 das ist hier einfach nur wichtig
dass ihr hier insgesamt 300 km h
ich finde das verhältnis ganz gut wenn
ihr 200 gramm von dem festeren habt also
mascarpone oder joghurt und 100 gramm
mehl und da können da war alles nehmen
was ihr gehabt als auch schmand oder
quark aber ich finde mascarpone und
joghurt ein mit sich dafür am besten
und jetzt gebt ihr zuerst die eier in
einer schüssel
und da kommt dazu können wir dazu und
das ganze wird jetzt auf höchster stufe
solange gerührt bis die masse richtig
schön dick ist
so soll das ganze dann aussehen also
richtig steif und jetzt kommen alle
anderen zutaten betreiben
bei ganzen trägerstoffe einmal
eingeführt ihr könnt das ganze aber auch
mit dem schneebesen unterrühren
so sollte der teig dann zum schluss
aussehen also auch keine klümpchen mehr
haben wenn ihr sichergehen wollte dass
ihr keine so kleinen stückchen drin habt
dann verrührt die mascarpone oder den
joghurt vorhalt gut mit der milch dann
habt ihr auch keine kleine blümchen mit
drin
jetzt gebe ich hier etwas öl in einer
pfanne und verteilt es einmal mit meinem
pinsel und dann gebe ich hier einfach
jetzt kleine mengen in die pfanne
ebenso groß wie es haben wollte und das
ganze lasse ich dann bei mittlerer stufe
etwa zwei bis drei minuten von jeder
seite backen
zu sehen dann die fertigen pancakes
ausgesehen und insgesamt 19 stück
geworden und wir sehen richtig schön
fluffig und stieg so wie eben per kick
sein müssen
die könnt ihr jetzt mit etwas ahornsirup
servieren oder einfach mit puderzucker
bestäuben die samir reiß dir ganz gern
mit etwas nutella
da könnte die wirklich so essen wie ihr
das möchte damit ihr richtig schöne
fluffige pancakes bekommt so wie hier
müsst ihr euch wirklich ganz genau an
die menge halten und auch an die
zubereitungs schritte ist nämlich ganz
wichtig dass die eier musste am anfang
richtig lange gerührt wird als mieter
kitchenaid dauert es etwa zwei minuten
mit meiner alten küchenmaschine hat das
immer bis zu zehn minuten gedauert
und falls ihr mit einem handrührgerät
arbeitet kann es auch richtig 10 bis 15
minuten dauern bis die masse eben
richtig schön fluffig cremig und weiss
ist jetzt habe ich ja dieses mal die
version mit etwas natron ausprobiert da
bin ich jetzt wirklich selbst positiv
überrascht ich werde es jetzt nur noch
zumachen
ich hatte einen telefonat räume und zwei
gestrichener teelöffel backpulver die
menge ist ganz gut so weil ich mag es
nicht so sehr viel zu viel backpulver im
teide ist und ich bin zwei teelöffel
backpulver auch schon ziemlich viel wie
gesagt könnt ihr die milchprodukte
austauschen eben einfach das was ihr da
habt ob joghurt oder schmand oder
mascarpone wobei ich die version in
ascona am meisten mag ich meine es hat
ja auch am meisten fett und fettig
amtsträger und jetzt wünsche ich einfach
mal viel spaß beim nachbacken probiert
auf jeden fall mal aus ihr könnt mir
dann gerne eure fotos bei facebook auf
meiner pinnwand posten das rezept gibt
es wie immer zum nachlesen auf meinem
blog auf www konzerten welt.de und dann
sehen wir uns schon bald wieder mit
einem neuen rezept und dann sage ich mal
bis bald